bom é hoje o tema é um tema que eu estou
observando aqui atrás
mundo um pouco nervoso com medo meio
ansioso ea gente começou a pensar como
que um palco o microfone uma platéia
causa tanta ansiedade em todo mundo né
todo mundo que teve a oportunidade de
estar aqui um dia ou assumiu algum palco
percebeu isso
até aqueles que são mais experientes que
dominam a arte da oratória
eles têm aquele friozinho na barriga
quando precisam falar
uma pesquisa recente nacional sobre os
maiores medos do brasileiro veio
relacionado ao medo de falar em público
o maior deles
se você joga no google a uma pesquisa
rápida sobre medo essa palavrinha
aparece mais de 90 milhões de vezes
é uma das palavras mais pesquisadas no
mundo é o que mais incomoda as pessoas
mas que joga tanto medo nas pessoas e
venho pensando e comecei a estudar
bastante sobre isso
comecei a tentar entender as
características do porquê do medo
e aí eu comecei a fazer uma pergunta pra
mim mesmo o que eu faria se eu não
tivesse medo ou o que eu teria feito até
que se eu não tivesse medo que eu teria
tido outras escolhas teria mudado a
minha história profissional
os meus caminhos minha formação que tipo
de experiência eu teria tido quais os
países cidades eu teria conhecido
se eu não tivesse medo e essa reflexão
eu gostaria que cada um de vocês
fizessem com alguns segundos caso você
tivesse um papel uma caneta e você
pudesse refletir por poucos segundos o
que você faria se não tivesse medo de
ser quem você realmente acredita que é
que você anotaria nesse papel
você seria a pessoa que você é hoje você
estaria fazendo trabalhando com que você
trabalha hoje que você faria
as razões não vivemos de acordo com que
realmente acreditamos seja por questões
culturais
o família por empresa o relacionamento
quantas vezes eu me decepcionei por ter
vivido um amor que não foi o amor que eu
gostaria de ter tido muitas vezes eu me
frustrei por ter tido paixões que não
foram as paixões que eu escolhi e o medo
me limitou a partir para novos desafios
eu já permanece no emprego que eu não
gostava do emprego mas eu tinha medo de
mudar simplesmente porque eu tinha
preocupação de não conseguir um outro
emprego ou pagar as minhas contas e aí
eu pensei se eu tivesse feito aquela
escolha
se eu não tivesse tido medo que eu teria
feito
quantas vezes a gente se cala
quantas vezes você sabe do que está
falando mas se limita a emitir a sua
opinião uma reunião com os amigos num
relacionamento
simplesmente pelo medo de achar que o
outro vai imaginar algo diferente de
você
quantas vezes nos calamos em diversas
situações
o medo nos bloqueio medo nos limita o
medo faz com que nos sintamos sufocado
sejamos cada vez mais pressionados antes
do medo tem algo que tinha envelope que
te abraça que a ansiedade ansiedade de e
do receio de não conseguir fazer as
escolhas certas
se você vai voltar ou se você vai fugir
e um pouco pior do que a ansiedade do
que o medo muita gente consegue
transformar tudo isso em uma fobia
você vê essa imagem o que congela o que
te faz ficar estagnado diante de uma
situação entender os nossos medos
essencial para entender se
estamos vivendo o nosso verdadeiro eu
quais são as nossas escolhas quais são
os nossos sonhos
qual que é a nossa verdadeira história o
que nós gostaríamos de viver o quanto
estamos decidindo sobre as nossas vidas
a crescente necessidade de adequação
como mina numa escolha de não ser você
cada vez mais um exemplo clássico disso
hoje no país temos mais de 13 milhões de
pessoas desempregadas e todos os dias
milhões de pessoas saem com uma
entrevista de emprego
quantas dessas pessoas têm medo de uma
pessoa chamada entrevistador conta
dessas pessoas não conseguem expressar a
sua real seu currículo a sua real pessoa
quando estão na frente de um
entrevistador
o mais interessante de tudo isso e eu
gosto de trazer a minha própria
experiência
lembro que a minha primeira entrevista
de emprego foi marcante para mim eu
decorei tudo sobre a empresa
tentem entender todos os protocolos
houve um tanto de gente conselhos fala
isso vai com essa roupa começa falando
de você e escolha os seus três adjetivos
mais importante tem se nos seus defeitos
estudei todos os protocolos processo
seletivo e a caminho daquela entrevista
anos idade começou a tomar conta de mim
parece que ele se prepare o ambiente diz
pega na entrevista que deixa as pessoas
mais nervosas e eu estava bem nervoso
ansioso já pensando no tipo de pergunta
que o entrevistador poderia fazer pra
mim
e aquela ansiedade foi se tornando um
medo do que iria acontecer dentro
daquela sala
na primeira pergunta do entrevistador eu
congelei no tive medo eu não consegui
expressar o que eu realmente queria
dizer não consegui ser eu mesmo
isso fez com que eu falhasse propagasse
miseravelmente
eu precisava muito daquele emprego e eu
não consegui isso acontece todos os dias
o medo é que nos tira tudo aquilo que a
gente tem de melhor que é a sua essência
é um você é ser você mesmo
quanto mais a gente tenta mostrar algo
que a gente não é mas a gente tem a
dificuldade de encarar os nossos medos
enfrentar o nosso mesmo os nossos medos
é nos despir de todo tipo de máscara
javatá todo tipo de protocolo de ritual
de textos prontos
fazer o quê norma temos possibilidade de
fazer que é ser nós mesmos é aprender a
lidar com os nossos medos todos os dias
é difícil mas é o nosso desafio como ser
humano
nós somos únicos nós somos especiais
cada um que tem uma história diferente
tem um caso diferente tem um exemplo
diferente e mais rico nisso tudo que
depois de anos eu fui trabalhar com
gestão de pessoas
fui trabalhar com recursos humanos e aí
eu fui sentado do outro lado da mesa do
processo de seleção e eu pude nesses 15
anos entrevistar mais de mil pessoas
conhecer diversas histórias jornadas
dilemas pessoas que tinham histórias
fantásticas que impactaram a minha vida
que mudaram a minha forma de ver o mundo
que agregará muito mais do que muitas
escolas o curso que fiz não podia
aprender com essas pessoas e essas
pessoas num processo de entrevista
muitas delas chegavam com histórias
fantásticas mas elas não conseguiam ser
elas mesmas
elas trabalhavam elas congelavam elas
não conseguiram transmitir a mensagem
muitos até choravam isso acontece todos
os dias
a gente precisa mudar essa história e
como que a gente pode fazer essa mudança
como que a gente consegue tornar essa
relação mais saudável mais leve intensa
mas não pensa
forma que a conexão seja e as pessoas
consiga ser elas mesmas
independente da relação se a uma
entrevista de emprego
se é no bate-papo em café se no seu
relacionamento com seus colegas de
trabalho na escola tornar a aprender se
colocar no lugar do outro vai de você
uma pessoa diferente minimiza o medo do
outro
a gente não tem expressado o nosso eu da
forma que a gente tem sido na década de
50 os nossos avós riam muito mais três
vezes mais do que a gente ri hoje
pense no que seria se você pudesse
expressar a sua liberdade
o seu eu a sua forma sem se preocupar
com o ambiente à qual você está sem se
preocupar com os protocolos com jargões
com o que o outro vai pensar
pense nos ambientes corporativos nas
organizações
pense no mercado financeiro dos
advogados
todos têm os seus protocolos os seus
rituais
quantas dessas pessoas não estão no
carro no local adequado que eles tanto
gostaria de ser como está
lembro que trabalhei por cinco anos
dentro de uma organização que eu tinha
que usar gravata todos os dias é e essa
sensação é uma das características que
mais me sufocava não era simplesmente
por usar a gravata mas todos os rituais
e protocolos que vinham junto daquele
pacote e quando eu tive a oportunidade
de não pertencer mais aquele ambiente
isso mudou a história isso mudou minha
vida e eu pude ser eu
isso tem acontecido muitos nos dias de
hoje não permita não tenha medo da
rejeição às vezes você se permite a esse
ambiente aceita essa pressão
simplesmente por não acreditar em você
atualmente as organizações têm falado
muito pouco sobre isso
existem diversas doenças síndrome de
burnout síndrome do pânico nunca se
falou tanto de doenças organizacionais
do ambiente organizacional e o que nós
temos feito em prol disso de que formas
temos discutido para tornar esse
ambiente mais leve mais colaborativo
quanto mais autêntico espontâneo somos
mas conseguimos minimizar o impacto que
o medo tem sobre nós
quanto mais sabemos ser antes de
aparecer mas nós nos distanciamos dos
nossos medos é ter mente de principiante
nas relações é entrar sem julgar é
entender a outra pessoa como ela é como
ela demonstra ser é se permitir ser
impactado a gente entra hoje nas
relações nas entrevistas nas conversas
já pensando nas respostas que queremos
dar as suas opiniões ou a conversa que o
outro nos transmite a gente não se
disponibiliza mais ao vilã que é uma
habilidade essencial nos dias de hoje
ser um agente de transformação no
ambiente organizacional não é algo
simples você precisa trabalhar as suas
histórias em uma organização tecnológica
moderna que pensa impacto e que também
precisa ser humana
todas as grandes empresas marcas brenin
ela se por trás tem pessoas têm conexões
têm sonhos e tem medos e que precisam
ser trabalhados discutidos e fazer parte
da nossa história no dia-a-dia ser quem
você é assumir o controle da sua vida é
olhar para frente é deixar para trás
todos os medos
é assumir os riscos da liberdade é ter
coragem e eu aprendi que o que é ter
coragem
seja corajoso não é o que o meu pai me
ensinava alguns anos atrás precisa ser
corajoso filho sem pagar josú é agir com
o coração é agir com um sentimento com
emoção nas relações a qual você se
envolve isso é ser corajoso ser corajoso
é ser capaz de mudar não só sua história
mudar a história das pessoas que estão
perto de você que estão ao seu redor é
ajudá-las a vencerem os seus medos
ajudá-las a carregarem mais os sonhos e
menos medo é que eles consigam crescer
cada vez mais dentro da sua essência
somos todos capazes de superar os nossos
medos pra isso precisamos estar a nossa
coragem
a gente precisa acreditar e ter
confiança
sob a perspectiva do medo ansiedade e
angústia das fobias um dos principais
caminhos para que você atinja o seu
objetivo e consiga vencer e se seus
obstáculos é partindo pela confiança
sendo corajoso e eu gostaria de
compartilhar com você que ser plural é
confiar em ser você mesmo é ter coragem
é agir com o coração é aumentar a nossa
capacidade de controlar controlar os
nossos medos e ser de fato quem você é
independente da relação o que você faria
se você não tivesse medo de ser quem
você realmente é
[Aplausos]